the gyro can experience now use I was
blessed to have died along with the BB
King on a number of occasions related
the king in a lot of ways King not
because he was the greatest blues
artists but because he was a great blues
artist you know through his personality
and through his generosity was able to
create such a presence that he becomes
the king in that way I had a chance to
see him live
you saw him yes he started was that at
the very end when he was sitting most of
the time no he was still standing
stammers in late 90s oh yeah no no you
absolutely it's a power out of his voice
and me but he used to say that the Blues
was a kind of high school visa Vee the
Jazz who are those who went to college
hmm and by college he meant just
studying with yeah but Armstrong would
do could ruffle foot in the really
Williams and the others and I always
tell myself I don't know about that
because you know the genius and
excellence comes in a number of
different forms most jazz musicians
don't have the genius of a Robert
Johnson and yet you know Charlie
Christians guitar is more complicated in
a variety of different ways in Robert
Johnson too so that you had to be able
to be flexible enough to see the
difference is the development building
on the genius of those who came before
so you can end up being a very good
guitar player who plays some
unbelievable chords that Jimi Hendrix
created yes but you build it on Jimmy
right and it becomes almost not taken
for granted but something you can use as
a launching pad like Stevie Ray Vaughan
did yes yes he rose vibration that's a
great examine at his own feel to it
absolutely absolutely and here again you
see you have the that common humanity
that cuts across color and there's a lot
of controversy these days about cultural
appropriation you know can white
brothers and sisters really
be part of a black genre and so forth
and so on I had a dialogue at my class
at Harvard uh this spring I teach a
course on black intellectual tradition
and I include some white intellectuals
as part of it was a strange career of
Jim Crow for example by the great C Vann
Woodward history at Jim Crow - the Bible
monitor the King set was the Bible -
civil rights movement Woodward was a
white southern brother and I would and I
have to miss a way to understand
completely brother West I said well let
me ask you this
it's Eminem a part of the hip-hop
tradition at the highest level yes he is
yes he is that's what we talked about
hmm you had to be a fool to deny the
genius of Eminem yeah Eminem you see but
there's no imminent went out dr. Dre and
so forth so he immerses and soaks
himself in it but he puts his own
distinctive stamp on it
Halla Noakes would be another Righteous
Brothers another average white band
mm-hmm from Scotland Wow well you know
that was right babe and the funk that
David Jenner yeah
oh my god now of course no average white
man without James Brown James Brown I
took it to places nobody took right but
right you let those guys brothers play
person-to-person on you yeah Oh Lord
let's pick up the pieces Oh why and it's
slow magic I mean it's just soulful man
you see Scotland Scotland Robert Burns
mm-hmm David Hume colonized by the
British Empire responding in their own
creative ways and by the 20th century
they soaked in rhythm and blues Wow
Korea's like that today
really oh man you know come you pop kpop
and Kate rhythm and blue I know they've
got a lot of break dancers over there oh
was not just BTS now BTS is something
else they they pack massive squares on
but I'm talking about like Urban's
service economy oh you put on coffee man
oh lord have mercy
I played that today and Danny Glover the
other day on the Bernie Sanders campaign
we traveled way off in the country in
South Carolina for brother Bernie I say
Danny is Sam Cisco I said listen these
young Korean brothers man
they don't remind you the natural for
Richmond I put it on oh man here came to
Korea what you talk about those Koreans
got a soulful sound man at a blow your
mind I've just reading a book called the
birth of Korean cool well it's just a
wall I don't know and it shows again how
you know that human spirit has always
grounded in something local in
particular like black music but it
travels it's it's it's the roots and the
routes yeah so the roots are black but
the RO Utes is global
[Applause]